ya hemos sido capaces de explorar
muchísimo a partir de nuestro pequeño
experimento mental verdad donde donde yo
me encontraba a la deriva aquí estoy yo
y me encuentro a la deriva en el espacio
verdad así que en este caso yo sería el
origen de mi propio marco de referencia
y justo al tiempo de igual a cero tengo
una amiga que pasa justo sobre de mí en
una nave espacial ahora debería dibujar
mejor esta nave espacial justo al tiempo
de igual a cero pasa por encima de mi
verdad y esta nave espacial lleva a una
velocidad ve muy bien y va en digamos en
la dirección positiva del eje x en donde
por supuesto por simplicidad para todos
estos vídeos sólo nos estamos fijando en
una dimensión verdad en una dimensión
digamos espacial y pensamos justamente
en el acertijo de los vídeos anteriores
donde había que pensar cómo hacerle para
que la velocidad de la luz sea siempre
la misma en cada marco de referencia
para lograrlo necesitamos reconsiderar
la idea del espacio-tiempo la idea del
espacio-tiempo y que de hecho lo estoy
diciendo bastante rápido porque tiene
que quedarse clara la idea de que a
diferencia de la idea intuitiva en donde
digamos pensamos al espacio y al tiempo
como como cosas independientes en
realidad cuando hablamos del
espacio-tiempo en realidad estamos
pensando en un solo continuo y cuando
empezamos a hacer diagramas de
espacio-tiempo nos dimos cuenta de que
para que para que la velocidad de la luz
fuera absoluta entonces el tiempo y el
espacio no pueden ser absolutos ni
tampoco pueden ser independientes como
nosotros creíamos y así es como
construimos estos diagramas de
espacio-tiempo de minkowski verdad para
cada uno de nuestros marcos de
referencia así que por ejemplo para mí
estoy representando el marco de
referencia en blanco verdad este sería
mi propio marco de referencia
mientras que en azul estoy pintando el
marco de referencia de mi amiga verdad
este sería el marco de referencia de mi
amiga y está pintado en azul verdad
entonces aquí los los ángulos verdad
estos ángulos que puedo pintar aquí son
serán dependientes de la velocidad
relativa que lleve mi amiga en su en su
nave espacial verdad va a ser
dependiente de la velocidad relativa que
lleve a mi marco con respecto a mi marco
de referencia muy bien entonces de hecho
estos ángulos se pueden calcular
explícitamente el ángulo alfa este
ángulo será la tangente inversa o el
arco tangente de la velocidad relativa
de mi amiga dividido entre la velocidad
de la luz muy bien y de hecho este
ángulo que tenemos aquí también será
alfa que es
tangente inversa de la velocidad
relativa dividida entre la velocidad de
la luz entonces mientras más rápido
tienda digamos tienda mi amiga a moverse
en esa nave espacial
estas dos rectas tenderán a irse a
apachurra no digamos o van a tratar de
colapsar en la recta que tiene un ángulo
de 45 grados muy bien entonces todo esto
ha resultado ser bastante interesante
pero algunos de ustedes quizás quieran
quieran ver un ejemplo digamos con
números tangibles verdad así que vamos a
vamos a pensar en este ejemplo en este
digamos en este evento que se encuentra
en el diagrama de espacio-tiempo verdad
y vamos a encontrar sus coordenadas
verdad entonces por ejemplo si
quisiéramos encontrar las coordenadas de
este punto con respecto a mi marco de
referencia lo único que tenemos que
hacer es trazar una recta vertical
verdad ver dónde intersecta a nuestro
eje blanco
y eso sería la coordenada x verdad
mientras que trazamos una recta
horizontal para saber su coordenada sete
verdad aquí estaría la coordenada x muy
bien entonces en realidad nosotros ya
vimos en un vídeo anterior por qué esto
es así verdad desde tal suerte que el la
coordenada 7 en realidad se puede medir
en metros y que pues si así lo prefieres
puedes pensar que son metros luz muy
bien ahora si nosotros quisiéramos
calcular las coordenadas de este evento
en términos del marco de referencia x
prima 7 prima tendríamos que trazar
rectas paralelas en este caso al eje x
prima para encontrar la coordenada 7
prima verdad de este evento y tendríamos
que trazar una recta paralela al eje 7
prima verdad para encontrar la
coordenada x prima muy bien entonces
cómo es que podemos transformar nuestra
coordenada x 7 en las coordenadas x
prima y 7 prima entonces para hacerlo
voy a tener que introducir en este vídeo
el concepto de lo que son las
transformaciones de lorentz muy bien
entonces vamos a hablar de las
transformaciones transformaciones de
lorentz
laurent
transformaciones de lawrence entonces en
esencia lo que hacen las
transformaciones de lawrence es tomar
las coordenadas x 7 y convertirlas en
las coordenadas x prima 7 prima entonces
vamos a ponerlo así las coordenadas x
prima
es la idea de las transformaciones de
lawrence y espero que al menos en este
vídeo se ve a un poquito la asimetría
que tienen y en realidad puedes verlas
digamos escritas de forma distinta
dependiendo del libro o la referencia
que esté consultando pero vamos a tratar
de reconciliar todas esas todas esas
asimetrías que podemos observar muy bien
entonces vamos a antes de comenzar
digamos propiamente con las
transformaciones del lawrence vamos a
definir lo que es el factor de lawrence
en el factor de lawrence lo
representamos con la letra griega gamma
muy bien y esto simplemente será uno
dividido entre la raíz cuadrada de uno
menos de cuadrada sobre s cuadrada donde
recordemos que b es la velocidad
relativa de la nave espacial de mi amiga
y se es la velocidad de la luz verdad
entonces a veces este este mismo factor
de lawrence gamma se escribe como uno
dividido entre la raíz d
1 - beta cuadrada yo no se preguntara
bueno quien es esta beta quien sería en
este caso beta que estoy pintando ahora
con este color azul y en realidad beta
lo podemos calcular o se define más bien
como la velocidad relativa dividida
entre la velocidad de la luz y este
digamos esta variable beta aparece
muchísimo siempre que estemos trabajando
en teoría de la relatividad verdad
entonces por ejemplo por ejemplo aquí
aparece que el ángulo es el la tangente
inversa de la velocidad relativa
dividida entre la velocidad de la luz
entonces esto realmente sería la
tangente inversa de beta verdad sería la
tangente inversa de beta entonces ahora
sí veamos cómo escribir nuestras
transformaciones del lawrence entonces
lo que vamos a hacer es calcular la
coordenada x prima la coordenada x prima
en términos
de la coordenada x 7 y esa simplemente
será gamma que multiplica a x x menos
beta
- beta por 7 por 7 muy bien eso sería la
coordenada x prima y si nosotros
queremos calcular ahora la coordenada 7
prima entonces esto será gamma
nuevamente que multiplica ahora y aquí
es donde viene digamos la parte de la
simetría verdad sería 7 menos beta por x
muy bien beta por x ésta es estas son
las transformaciones de lawrence muy
bien entonces en este caso quiero que
quiero que aprecies cómo es que estas
transformaciones dan cuenta de que el
espacio y el tiempo tan son digamos son
sólo dos direcciones del mismo continuo
verdad y hay hay una linda simetría aquí
por ejemplo aquí tenemos la coordenada x
y aquí tenemos la coordenada x verdad en
este lado también tenemos la coordenada
y acá tenemos la coordenada 7 verdad
entonces en esencia las transformaciones
del orden nos dicen que para calcular la
coordenada x prima de un mismo evento en
términos de las coordenadas anteriores x
7 primero hay que rescatar por un factor
y este factor es el factor de laurent y
luego multiplicamos
x menos beta por cts verdad gamma
multiplica a todo ese número y luego
para calcular la coordenada 7 prima
tenemos otra vez que escalar digamos con
este factor gamma verdad y multiplicamos
ahora digamos como intercambiando el
papel verdad
7 - beta x hemos intercambiado el papel
de 7 y el de equis y esto esto quizás te
parezca como si como si estuviéramos
hablando en griego y de hecho estamos
usando letras griegas pero en el
siguiente vídeo voy a usar ciertos
números de ejemplo para que veas que
calcular dichas transformaciones tan
sólo se trata de álgebra elemental